este es el vídeo de física esencial
número 4 y hablaremos del átomo tal vez
se acuerden de ernest rutherford y del
experimento que hizo con una lámina de
oro eso ayudó a que los científicos
descubrieron el pequeño núcleo positivo
que hay en el centro de un átomo pero
eso no nos explica qué pasa con los
electrones rutherford solo supuso que se
mueven alrededor del núcleo más o menos
como los planetas se mueven alrededor
del sol pero otro investigador niels
bohr encontró un problema en esto él
sabía que cualquier partícula cargada y
en movimiento genera una radiación
electromagnética con lo que pierde
energía y con esa suposición terminaría
deteniéndose en el centro del átomo él
sabía que eso no estaba bien pero
también sabía que la longitud de onda de
la radiación puede variar y eso nos
lleva al bonito de espectro
electromagnético que se genera por
átomos de altas energías entonces cuando
los científicos
empezaron a analizar el espacio
descubrieron que la luz no era tan
simple y que tiene algunas unidades
discretas así que había que describir
mejor al espectro y en eso nos ayudó
mucho el modelo de voz miren este es el
modelo atómico del hidrógeno que boro
investigó aquí tenemos estos niveles de
energía y un electrón puede estar en el
nivel 1 2 o 3 pero nunca lo vamos a
encontrar en medio de dos niveles y como
cambia de nivel bueno si absorbe energía
de un fotón como por ejemplo por
radiación electromagnética el electrón
brincará a un nivel más alto y cuando
regresa emite ese fotón esa es una buena
explicación del espectro entonces ahora
sabemos que tenemos una nube de
electrones y el núcleo en la nube
tenemos electrones que están cargados
negativamente y en el núcleo tenemos
protones y neutrones pero miren en un
átomo neutro existe
el mismo número de electrones y de
protones y sobre todo los electrones nos
pueden dar mucha información sobre las
propiedades de ese átomo
de hecho la tabla periódica está hecha
por los electrones específicamente los
de niveles de energía externos ahora el
modelo de vor nos ayuda a explicar qué
hacen los electrones y cómo se mueven y
eso nos ayuda a explicar el espectro por
ejemplo si analizamos un átomo de la
tabla periódica el número atómico que en
este caso es 2 nos dice cuántos protones
tenemos estos son los protones que
encontraremos en el núcleo recuerden que
son positivos y para calcular los
neutrones simplemente restamos la masa
atómica
- el número atómico así sabemos que por
ejemplo en el caso del helio hay 2
neutrones ahora como en un átomo neutro
el número de protones y de electrones es
igual podemos deducir que tenemos 2
electrones moviéndose alrededor del
núcleo así que el número de electrones
de un átomo nos puede decir mucho sobre
las propiedades de ese
y si analizamos la tabla periódica todo
esto fue creado a partir del número de
electrones de cada átomo por ejemplo
aquí tenemos cobre plata y oro que son
muy parecidos y como se encuentran en la
misma columna eso nos dice que sus
electrones más externos son muy
similares y si analizamos la primera
columna todos estos elementos son
altamente reactivos a diferencia de
todos los gases nobles y todas esas
propiedades las conocemos por los
electrones pero aún había problemas con
este modelo porque los electrones no se
mueven alrededor del núcleo como se
mueven los planetas en realidad los
electrones están saltando de un nivel a
otro de acuerdo a lo que dijo niels bohr
entonces un electrón se mueve de un lado
a otro a través de una infinidad de
niveles que existen alrededor del núcleo
generando así el espectro y pasa algo
muy parecido a una
era el electrón puede estar aquí o
también podría estar aquí pero nunca lo
veremos en medio y se dice que es
cuantificado porque se encuentra en una
unidad específica ahora cómo podríamos
mover un electrón a un nivel superior
necesitaríamos aplicar energía entonces
si tenemos mucha energía el electrón
puede brincar hasta este nivel y
conforme regresa libera una cierta
cantidad de energía
esta es una animación de cómo se ve el
átomo devore observen cómo el electrón
se mueve alrededor del núcleo pero
cuando recibe un fotón brinca a un nivel
más alto de energía y si libera esa
energía regresa al nivel en el que se
encontraba esto nos ayuda a explicar el
espectro porque antes de que se supiera
de la existencia del modelo de x ya se
empezaba a estudiar el espectro luminoso
al observar el espacio con un
espectroscopio que separa la luz en las
diferentes longitudes de onda
empezaron a ver estas líneas por ejemplo
si veían hacia el sol que contiene mucho
hidrógeno podemos ver todas estas series
la serie del imán fue desarrollada por
un científico que usó la espectroscopia
y encontró una ecuación que explica algo
que sucede pero que no podemos ver
porque está en el espectro ultravioleta
y también está la serie de pajín que
muestra lo mismo pero en el espectro
infrarrojo y la serie de valmer es lo
mismo pero en el espectro que podemos
ver el visible y lo que en realidad
explican son todas estas unidades
discretas de la luz pero de dónde viene
esa luz bueno si analizamos el hidrógeno
podemos ver que si nos movemos del nivel
de energía 2 al 3 se necesita una cierta
cantidad de energía y si el electrón
regresa liberará esa energía así que el
modelo de x ayudó a predecir todos estos
números que actualmente coinciden
perfectamente con lo que sabemos del
espectro
bueno esto solo aplica para el hidrógeno
pero es un buen modelo para empezar lo
aprendieron aprendieron la estructura de
los niveles de energía de un electrón en
un átomo en la escala que se investiga
en este caso los niveles de energía del
átomo de hidrógeno espero que les sirva